Europe is now officially eating the bugs
the European Union has officially
enacted a statute allowing food
producers to incorporate Cricket powder
into flower-based products bread
crackers cereal bars biscuits beer like
beverages chocolate soups sauces a bunch
of other items they just grind up the
Crickets guts and excrement and all and
then pack them into your food now it is
not exactly mandatory
but it kind of is because many if not
most people are going to end up eating Z
bugs without even knowing it think about
all the bizarre junk that is already
packed into your food seed oils
preservatives polysyllabic chemicals
that most people can't even pronounce
let alone identify well now they're
adding ground up crickets and there
isn't much most people can do about it